have you ever received an email like
this
or maybe this
or how about this
of course you have most of us just
delete it and yet they still come so the
more important question is do these
emails actually work how much money do
they make and who is dumb enough to fall
for these horribly written emails the
short answer they are shockingly
effective and absolutely work in fact
these nigerian prince operations make
millions and more people fall for it
than you think but to really understand
how the business of nigerian prince
emails work you have to put yourself in
the shoes of one of these nigerian
princess i mean email scammers and by
the end of this video you're gonna want
to pretend to be one of these nigerian
princes as well
[Music]
like all good startups spamming started
small the first large chaos spamming
campaign was sent by a student in 1994.
the email subject was this global alert
for all jesus is coming soon this
student sent the message to every single
news group available and if it didn't
annoy almost everyone it did spark up a
lot of online arguments not long after
businesses and criminals started
realizing how profitable spamming can be
it was practically free since you didn't
have to pay for an ad listed in a
newspaper or junk mail sent to a bunch
of random houses and spamming went
mainstream by 2014 almost 85 of all
emails were spammed which means that
today building your scam empire as a
nigerian prince is easier than ever
[Music]
your very first step as a new spammer is
to choose your business model sure you
could make some money sending spam
emails for actual businesses or bombard
people's inbox with cheap viagra to get
a small commission but that is boring
we're criminals let's do something a
little bit more interesting
phishing you could send phishing emails
these emails try to get people to either
a enter their personal data banking
passwords or credit card information
into very legit looking websites b get
them to open malicious attachments that
take over their computers or phones or c
get them to open an attachment that
encrypts all their files until they pay
you a ransom to get it back we are
definitely not condoning criminal
activity on this channel this is purely
for entertainment purposes only
but not all of us are hackers or know
how to use ransomware so what other
spamming business models are there for
the less technologically sophisticated
enter the iconic nigerian print or long
lost royalty emails like the email we
all laughed at at the beginning of this
video nigerian royalty scams are almost
synonymous with spamming all you gotta
do is send out millions of emails
telling people you just inherited
millions of dollars and that you're
scared that someone will steal it or you
want to avoid taxes and then you want to
follow up with the fact that the person
you're mailing who you've never met
before is the only person you can trust
to keep your money safe to most of us it
sounds ridiculous but to a select few
victims it can really seem like the
offer of a lifetime once they take the
bait and reply you move forward and tell
them just how happy you are to have
found someone so trustworthy but and
there's always a but you have a problem
they will have to pay for the
transaction fee the legal fee transfer
fee or whatever you want to call it
paying 50 in exchange for 5 million
seems like a pretty sweet deal right
well i think we all know the answer to
that once they pay the fee you make sure
they never hear from prince solomon
again and they will probably just write
off that 50 as a stupid mistake but you
take that 50
and add it to the thousands of other
people who also fell for your scam and
you're sitting on a nice little fortune
and if you play your cards right you can
make up to 60 million dollars just from
sending a few billion emails once you've
decided how you're going to spam and
scam people it's time to set up your
operation
[Music]
the idea behind spamming is pretty
simple if you send out enough emails at
least one person has to be dumb enough
to fall for your lies how many emails it
takes to get one victim is called your
conversion rates once you have your
conversion rate all you have to do is
decide how much money you want to make
and work backwards to figure out how
many emails that would take for example
it takes at least 12.5 million spam
emails to get one response that's a
response rate of 0.0008
and even then that response doesn't mean
that person will actually go through
with giving you their money you still
have to sell them on it now a zero point
zero zero zero zero zero eight percent
response rate may not sound like a lot
but it is if you're sending more than a
billion emails a day like the best
scammers do a billion emails at a 0.0008
response rate is still 8 000 suckers
every single day let's say you close
just one percent of those 8 000 suckers
into sending you 50 each that is 4 000 a
day or nearly 1.5 million dollars every
single year for emails that cost
practically nothing to send with
researchers estimating that these
profits could be even higher the trick
though is figuring out how to actually
send a billion emails a day
and if you happen to be annoyed by the
amount of spam that's filling up your
inbox no matter how many times you hit
unsubscribe or you don't like the idea
of companies selling your email to
spammers that is where mine comes in
today's video's sponsor and the sponsor
is free by the way so you're gonna want
to stick around mine is a smart data
assistant that lets you find out exactly
which companies have your data and lets
you delete your data from that company
with a simple click of a button when it
comes to spam or endless marketing
emails we all want to exercise our right
to be forgotten and mine makes that
possible all you gotta do is sign up for
free with the email address you want
analyzed and boom i had this many
companies that had my personal data when
most being ones i don't use or even know
about once mine shows you who has your
data you can scroll through the list and
choose the ones you want to delete like
this one that i don't use anymore but
the industry's breach potential is high
and it has my financial information
click the reclaim button and boom you
sent a data deletion request directly
from your inbox straight to the company
you want your data deleted at and if you
change your mind you can always head
back to the my reclaim section and undo
your request within the first hour with
so many spammers and criminals out there
dying to get their hands on your data
taking back control over who has access
to your personal information is not just
important for your online safety it can
stop you from getting bombarded by
thousands of nigerian princes wanting to
share their inheritance with you for a
small fee the added bonus is that mine
will notify you via email if new
companies are discovered to have your
data meaning you can always keep full
control over your digital footprint plus
mine is free right now so you have no
reason not to take back control of where
your data is stored at mine will be
switching to a subscription setup soon
so join now while you still can with the
link below that's saymine.com
[Music]
setting up the network needed to send
billions of emails every day could be a
little trickier emails are free but the
internet and computers aren't you could
try sending them from your own computer
but not only is that a giant security
problem but you'll never be able to send
out enough to be profitable so your best
option is to hijack as many pcs or
laptops belonging to other people as
possible and use these computer networks
known as botnets to send all your mail
once you have a network of computers
under your control not only can you send
out enough emails to make a lot of money
but your operating costs become
practically zero besides the cost of
actually getting the email addresses to
spam to which we'll cover later so now
that you have the infrastructure set up
it's time to figure out how to avoid the
dreaded spam filters
spam filters are a feature that almost
every email service provider has but how
good they are at figuring out that your
message is spam can vary the most basic
filters just look for keywords that a
lot of spammers use and send those
emails to your spam folder other
services go the extra mile and even
check where your mail is coming from who
is sending it and if they're trying to
avoid basic filters by using fake html
tags so in order to avoid all your hard
work going to waste by having your
perfectly crafted email end up in the
spam folder or worse you getting caught
you need to follow a few simple spamming
guidelines hide your contact info as
much as you can use dozens of different
email addresses for people to get in
contact with you and never link those
email addresses to your actual phone
number or name switch your ip addresses
as often as you change your underwear
make sure your email location jumps
around so much so that no one can
pinpoint you as a scammer use fake html
tags to confuse filters that are looking
for keywords and add random letters to
your subject lines and bodies this makes
it almost impossible for even the best
newest spam filters to figure you out
once you've brought your anti-spam
filtering skills to an art form your
next step is to get as many email
addresses as possible
[Music]
what is a spammer without anyone to spam
in order to get the ball rolling on your
spamming empire you're going to need
email addresses and a lot of them if
you're a small town spammer you might
resort to using email addresses made
public on linkedin or facebook but any
discerning spam aficionado knows that a
couple hundred addresses you can find
manually aren't anything compared to
what you can get on the black market
there are hundreds of sellers that are
happy to sell you millions of active
email addresses that they get from chat
rooms news groups or from using bots
that crawl the web looking for anything
with the ad symbol or if you're lucky
you can find someone who has access to
the email servers of email service
providers who is willing to share
millions of email addresses with you for
a small price so so far we've built the
infrastructure we've built up your email
address database now it's time to craft
your message
have you ever wondered why these
nigerian prince emails have so many
obvious spelling mistakes i mean so so
so many no matter what your message is
if you want people to buy your fake
pharmaceuticals send you their life
savings or even donate to your
charitable organization your main goal
is to have people who are actually
interested in what you're offering to
reply right so one of the best ways to
do that is to include lots of typos in
your mail now you may be thinking but
jake i want people to believe my
messages not notice a bunch of typos and
immediately think scam but that's the
whole point if your email has typos and
someone still replies you found the
perfect mark if a hundred thousand
people read your email almost fall off
their chairs laughing and send it
straight to the trash that's fine those
people would never send you money
anyways you don't want them to reply
they're too sophisticated to fall for
your trap you want the person who will
read through all your spelling and
grammar mistakes and still reply they're
the most gullible they're the ones most
likely to believe everything you tell
them as a scammer you prey on the most
believing the most innocent the most
naive and you do that by disqualifying
all the people who aren't gullible
enough via your typo and grammar
mistakes and once you've reached the
step where you have a bunch of email
addresses you know how to avoid spam
filters and have crafted the most
unbelievably believable message you're
ready to start sending
you're gonna be doing a lot of sending
back in 2003 aol blocked more than 88
spam messages per user per day so in
order to get your message through and
give you the best chance of getting a
response you need to aim for at least 1
billion emails a day if you want to play
in the big leagues and once you've
reached the rhythm where you're sending
billions of emails every week you can
sit back relax and watch those millions
of dollars start rolling in
[Music]
so now that you are a nigerian prince
making millions i know what you're
thinking but jake how am i supposed to
launder all this money so i can actually
spend it very astute observation because
yes the government is gonna wonder where
you're getting all this money from and
no you can't say that i got it from my
illegal nigerian prince operation well
you're in luck because we have videos
explaining exactly how to launder that
dirty money one shows you how to do it
with traditional methods and one with
crypto and as always these videos are
for entertainment purposes only both
will be linked below below the link for
our sponsored mind that you should check
out if you don't want to get these spam
emails yourself or if you want to take
back control of your data online mine is
free to use a great free product and
they're a big supporter of the channel
so you should check them out with the
link below at samemine.com if you are
new here we make video essays just like
this one on the most provocative stuff
in the world of money power crime and
war so definitely hit that red subscribe
button while you're down there and if
you want more behind the scenes stuff
then the live kind of stuff you can
follow me on instagram at jtrend.io that
is going to wrap it up for this video
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome i've been jake stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you